good morning believe nation today's
message is failed as fast as you can
over you Azim Premji we must allow for
creative failure when it comes to
generating ideas it is inevitable
no one likes failure particularly
business leaders but unfortunately all
evidence suggests that it is impossible
to generate few good ideas without a lot
of bad ideas and bad ideas are expensive
but they have to be tolerated as the
physics Nobel Prize winner faman said I
try to fail as fast as I can that is the
best way to move forward on a new idea
fail as fast as you can
failure should be forgiven and forgotten
as long as the lessons are remembered
and recycled this habit has come up a
number of times in a channel and I think
people are just too hung up on failure
they see failures this big permanent
thing that's as spot on their resume or
on their life and they can never
overcome it just change your mindset
about failure failure is going to happen
it means your your trying stuff you
cannot have success without failure they
are they are together you fail a bunch
of times you learn what not to do and
then you succeed the only way to not
have any failure is that you live in
life so safe that you've never tried
anything and in my view that's the
biggest failure of all the one thing I
might change in this line of thinking
though instead of fail as fast as you
can is try as fast as you can if you
have a new idea try it
it will likely lead to failure but maybe
it won't like maybe you'll find a way to
make it work or maybe it fails and then
you find another way to stay in and
another way to do it where I think too
many people have these big ideas that
they want to try right you've got this
goal that you have this life purpose or
something huge thing that you want to
try and you build it up to be this
massive project this massive idea and
the only way you're ever gonna take
action is if you line up all these
pieces well in order for me to do that
to do this this this and these people on
team I need to have venture capital
funding we need to have all of these
things aligned for me to do it and they
never aligned that stuff never happens
and so you never end up going for that
big dream of yours and then most people
end up dying with their song still in
them they die with that books to live
and they die with that business ideas to
live because they never took action
because there's always some big project
that they never had the resources to do
where what you want to do is break it
down
try as fast as possible find the
smallest possible way to get started and
get started on it if you have an idea
for something you want to do don't wait
a year 10 years or never to do it
find a small way to do it what will
happen is one you may go into it and
find out that you don't like it anymore
right like well that's a relief but I
didn't spend five years pining about
this certain industry or this dream job
or ideal business I want to start and
then figure out that it wasn't for me
right like that could give you amazing
knowledge that saves you a ton of time
or two you find out that you do love it
and it makes you come alive no matter
how much planning you do at the start no
matter how much planning for this ideal
business your plan will be wrong your
plan will change because the environment
changes the marketization change your
customers change but also you don't know
enough like you don't know enough until
you go down and actually try to do stuff
so you get out and you adjust and you
see what the customers want you see how
they're reacting so whatever it is that
you have this big idea in your head that
you haven't started on and you're
waiting for perfect resources and
opportunities to come along forget all
that
throw it out the door there's always a
smaller way to get started the trick to
moving forward on these big projects is
the moment that you set a goal you take
some kind of immediate action towards
achieving that goal no matter how small
some kind of immediate action towards
achieving that goal to start building up
momentum baby steps and I know you want
to take giant leaps but if you look back
at what helped make those giant leaps
for yourself and for other people it's
very rarely going from here to here it's
here to here to here to here and here to
here and then eventually get up there
right like a cumulation up
of little steps that lead to those big
steps you want to take that giant leaf
but you're not willing to take those
little baby steps that's how the big
things get done so as soon as you set a
goal for yourself as soon as you say I
wish I could do this get that out of
your vocabulary and start doing try as
fast as you can so the question of day
today is I'm curious what are you gonna
try today what big things you have in
mind and how can you break it down to
try it on a small scale and do something
with the resources you have today
leaving the comments below
I'm gonna join the discussion thank you
so much for watching have an amazing day
you seem to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
event